hello everyone welcome to a new video
and a new set of solutions for the CPP
for school thing that we're going
through were on assignments below
controlled Sat one problem for and this
is obviously on CVP for school comm and
in this series we're basically going
through the entirety of the inside of
these assignments and gonna walk through
all the solutions so we got a little
ways to go so let's keep going now
last video we left off right after
solving problem three so we're gonna
start on problem 4 here and we're
already in our folder so we're gonna go
ahead and open up our coding program
which is Visual Studio code here and I
write file looks fine it looks like we
just solved problem three not gonna
worry about that extension right now so
problem three looking good we're gonna
go ahead and comment that out and move
on to a problem for for so what this is
asking for is let's see write a program
to determine whether the seller has made
profit or incurred loss also determine
how much profit you made or how much
loss they incurred cost price and
selling price of an item is it input by
a user all right well that's a pretty
straightforward just use a little
subtraction and figure it out so not a
very hard one we're going to need a cost
let's see a float of cost profit loss
sell profit loss so we're gonna need all
those and we'll go ahead and ask for
some stuff cost of item so we'll get
that will also say item sold for and
we'll put sell there and then after we
have that information we can do some
processing we can say if let's see costs
- sell it's less than 0 then we can say
loss equals cost - sell this might not
be the best way of doing it but it'll
work so if we buy it at a price let me
sell it for another price that's well
there's probably a better way of saying
this okay so let's say we buy it for $2
and we sell it for $3 that's less than
zero so that's actually a profit if
we're calculating like this and how much
profit what would be the cost minus the
cell but also it would be the absolute
value of this so whatever the difference
is here now this is sort of a backwards
way of doing the math but that's the way
it's coming to mind for me so else
if this ends up being positive then
we'll then we lost because we sold it
for less than we bought it for so we
would say loss equals I guess this will
just be playing on cost - sell and then
that way it's only gonna work with one
of these variables so we could say well
we could just do it all in the same one
profit made and that's gonna be just
profit a new line there you know this
one maybe we could say loss incurred or
something like that let's go ahead and
just give it a quick try okay so we can
pile it and we get a cost of an item
let's say we bought something for I
don't know say $50 and we ended up
selling it for 55 profit made five
buckaroos alright so that seems to be
fine let's try it with a loss say we
bought something 45 and we can only
manage this out for 35 and we incurred a
loss of $10 so yeah that seems to be
straightforward enough to do the job now
like it was sort of mentioning it's
worth noting that there was a lot of
different ways you could do this
particular thing so that's just one way
of quickly getting it done
and I'm guessing the solution on here
it's going to look a little different
but as long as it get you the results
you need an accurate number then
typically your function or program is
fine let some hot coffee
hot hot coffee okay so number five let's
go to straight number five the ages of
RAM and I'm not sure how to say that
name and AJR input by the user write a
program to determine the youngest of the
three the youngest of the three okay
well this is a I'm sure a lot of you
already know how to do this um okay
let's just start while the age is going
to be an unsigned integer because ages
can't be negative can they you can't be
like negative one-year-old so unsigned
means it's positive only and integer cuz
we're not gonna work with 0.5 so we're
just gonna go straight with with years
we're not gonna say like five years two
months because it doesn't say - it's not
really specific so we'll do rampage will
do soul our you say this age and AJ age
and then we'll just take those in enter
the ages of RAM yeah all these guys
between okay so with spaces in between
that'll that'll basically just separate
them out in this
so if you want a ball once you can do
something like this
and every space you put in the CN will
separate it so once we have the ages we
can take a quick look and just see which
one is the lowest now what's the most
efficient way to flow this I don't know
there's only there's only a few three
different cases really there are uh is
the old way to see this want the oldest
youngest so one of them is the youngest
since the basic three different cases if
RAM age is less than so however you say
that age okay then we'll say I guess
we'll do another if here so Rams age is
less than this guy's then well we'll
just do it in line here and RAM age is
also less than AJ age well we Rams the
youngest so there's if Rams the youngest
that wool that will take care of it so
we can also do a few more cases here say
else--if now please someone correct me
in the comments of a better way to do
this because I'm not looking at the
solution I'm just doing this however it
works and it's probably a little
long-winded and unnecessary but that's
okay because sometimes you just got to
get the job done so now we're just
checking if Salama so you say that slab
is younger than RAM and younger than AJ
as if he is then we could say that celeb
if this is really an ounce lab madami
named slab I'm sorry if anyone use named
slab that's a real Washington name so
the other case is AJ is the youngest but
we don't take into account some equality
here because I don't know if some of
these ages are the same number then it's
just gonna say AJ is the youngest
because we don't have a final case here
so what we're gonna have to do is just
improvise a little bit and say AJ age is
less than Ram age
so yeah that's gonna have to be an
else--if rather than else because we do
need to do a little checking if we're
going to consider ages that are equal
and maybe some error cases of that so
there we go there's of AJ's the youngest
now the final case here basically if
none of these other ones end up being
true is there is a tie for the youngest
and we'll just stop there well not worry
about saying that because they don't say
anything about saying anything further
all right let's go ahead and take a
quick check on that so in other ages of
RAM slab and AJ with spacing between
let's say Ram is 28 slab is 15 and AJ is
I don't know 20 and it says I have is
the youngest 15 so that looks good
that's running again
and this time we'll put in 10 10 and 12
and we get a tie for the youngest so
this looks like it's gonna work pretty
consistently little flow of control was
a big if if else if else if else to
determine that
and if you think about it yeah this
makes sense because there are four cases
here there's really three outcomes of
one of them one of the three being the
youngest or the Ty case is the fourth
outcome that's not really mentioned by
the question at all but it's got to be
there they don't say anything about
equal or calculating months we're just
doing years okay so let's move on there
that was five looks like we got time for
maybe one more okay so we're on six
write a program to check whether a
triangle is valid or not when the three
angles of the triangle are entered by
the user a triangle is valid if the sum
of all three angles 280° right okay well
that's pretty straightforward
so we'll take six here now obviously we
can't have any negative angles so rather
than through the ages we're gonna say
enter the three triangle angles with
spaces in between and of course this
can't be an unsigned integer this is
really got to be a float but also can
there be negative angles not really I
mean to some extent you could sometimes
calculate them but they just basically
subtract off of 360 like negative 90 is
270 degrees so that makes sense
so we'll just saying one angle to equal
3 etc so we'll get three angles in and
they are floats and we want to make sure
none of these are negative
I guess well forget it it doesn't matter
we're not even gonna check that I mean
in a real program you probably would
so if those are equal to 180 under named
degrees we'll say that is a legal
triangle otherwise it's not and there we
go that should be enough to take care of
the basics of that question so let's say
we have I don't know a 50 degree angle a
45 degree angle you know 20 degree angle
and we get that as a legal triangle so
let's run it again let's even get a
legal try and go in here see what if we
get a 90 and what - 45 at 45 and a 45
that's legal and it's a legal triangle
very good so we could put in all kinds
of numbers there and it will just spit
it out they equal exactly under an 80
then we're good
otherwise it's not a legal triangle okay
that's all the time we have for today
thanks for tuning in hope this helps
some people out there figure out some
flow of control and some basics of C++
and how to write some basic logic and
I'll see you the next episode where we
will pick up on flow of control question
7 and see how far we can get thank you
very much peace out